abajo tenemos la gráfica de f se muestra
un total de 24 rectángulos circunscritos
qué quiere decir esos rectángulos
circunscritos son 24 rectángulos los
puedes contar y que sean circunscritos
quiere decir que la altura de todos los
rectángulos está determinada por el
valor de la función en el extremo
derecho del rectángulo aquí lo puedes
ver este es el extremo derecho del
primer rectángulo y si tomamos el valor
de la función en ese punto es la altura
del rectángulo para un rectángulo
inscrito la altura estaría determinada
por el valor de la función en el extremo
izquierdo del rectángulo este que estoy
marcando sería el primer rectángulo
inscrito es la diferencia entre
rectángulos inscritos y circunscritos 8
en azul aquí lo vemos y 16 en rojo
correcto todos los 24 rectángulos tienen
la misma base cuál de las siguientes
afirmaciones es o son verdaderas nos dan
tres expresiones en notación sigma y nos
dicen que la primera es la suma de las
áreas de los rectángulos azules la
segunda y la suma de las áreas de los
rectángulos rojos y la tercera en la
suma de las áreas de todos
ahora te invito a que le pongas pausa al
vídeo y trates de determinar por tu
cuenta cuál de estas afirmaciones es o
son verdaderas supongo que ya lo
intentaste y ahora vamos a revisar cada
una de estas a ver si hacen sentido la
primera la suma de las áreas de los
rectángulos azules veamos aquí tenemos 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 rectángulos azules y aquí
estamos sumando desde 1 hasta 8 estamos
sumando 8 cosas aquí 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 así
es que esta parte está bien y luego
estamos calculando efe de algo por un
medio
así es que aparentemente esta de aquí es
la altura de cada uno de los rectángulos
recuerda que estamos tomando rectángulos
circunscriptos y esta de aquí es la base
de los rectángulos veamos si hace
sentido que la base de los rectángulos
es un medio la distancia total del
intervalo que va de menos 5 a 7 es 12 57
son 12
estamos dividiendo entre 24 rectángulos
que tienen la misma base así es que al
dividir 12 entre 24 rectángulos
obtenemos que cada rectángulo tiene una
base de un medio así es que esto está
bien se checa que los rectángulos tienen
una base de un medio y ahora veamos esta
parte verifiquemos efe de menos 5 más y
sobre 2 veamos cuando iu es igual a 1
multiplicamos un medio por efe de menos
5 más 1 sobre 2 menos 5 más un medio y
es igual a 1 menos 5 más un medio nos
lleva a este punto que tenemos aquí
efe de eso es esta distancia que tenemos
aquí esta altura lo cual efectivamente
corresponde a un rectángulo circunscrito
así es que cuando y es igual a 1
definitivamente estamos encontrando el
área de este rectángulo ahora cuando y
es igual a 2 esto va a ser
efe de menos 5 + 2 sobre 2 2 sobre 2 es
1 al agregar 1 a menos 5 llegamos a este
punto de aquí de nuevo
estamos multiplicando un medio que es la
base del rectángulo por efe de menos 51
efe de menos 4 que es la altura de este
rectángulo para obtener el área y así
podemos continuar cada que aumente el
valor de iu en uno el valor de x aumenta
en un medio empezamos en menos 5 más un
medio y cada incremento del valor de ahí
va a resultar en un incremento de un
medio para el valor de x de tal manera
que el resultado final de la expresión
es la suma de las áreas de los ocho
primeros rectángulos por lo que esta
afirmación es de hecho correcta y la
expresión corresponde a la suma de las
áreas de los rectángulos azules ahora
analicemos esta de aquí la suma de las
áreas de los rectángulos rojos esto
parece interesante estamos tomando la
suma de 16 cosas y aquí tenemos 16 cosas
tenemos la base de esas 16 cosas de
hecho para cada una de estas cosas
queremos calcular el área y si el caso
es que cada una de estas cosas tiene una
base de un medio pero qué pasa cuando
evaluamos
efe de menos y más
así es que estamos empezando estamos
empezando aquí cuando x vale menos uno
ahora cuando y es igual a 1 el valor de
x va a ser menos 1 más un medio que
corresponde a este punto donde podemos
ver que el valor de la función es igual
a 0 la altura del rectángulo cuando i es
igual a 2
esta es la altura el rectángulo y cuando
i es igual a 3 la función va a ser la
altura de este rectángulo y aquí es
donde tenemos que tener mucho cuidado
pues aunque el valor absoluto de esto es
positivo vemos que el valor de la
función aquí de acuerdo a la gráfica es
negativo
así es que todos estos van a tener un
valor negativo pues como vemos aquí
entre x igual a este es el valor de x
igual a menos un medio y x igual a 7 el
valor de la función es negativo
podríamos pensar que aquí tenemos una
altura negativa que al multiplicar la
por la base positiva obtenemos un número
negativo así es que la suma de estos
valores va a ser un número negativo por
lo que estaríamos obteniendo al final de
cuentas el valor negativo de la suma de
las áreas de los rectángulos rojos que
no es lo mismo que la suma de las áreas
de los rectángulos rojos
y un área siempre tiene un valor
positivo si quisieras por ejemplo cubrir
esta región de alfombra requiere cierta
cantidad de alfombra lo cual es un valor
positivo pero con esta expresión se
obtiene el valor negativo de esa
cantidad así es que esto no es la suma
de las áreas de los rectángulos rojos es
menos la suma de las áreas de los
rectángulos rojos tachamos esta veamos
la última opción esta expresión es la
suma de las áreas de todos los
rectángulos la suma va desde igual a 1
hasta 24 está sumando 24 cosas empieza
aquí y continúa a todo lo largo del
intervalo si únicamente tomamos desde
iguala 1 hasta 8 es la primera opción
pero aquí nos encontramos con el mismo
problema a partir de e igual a 9 esto se
hace negativo con lo cual nos da por así
decirlo un área negativa por lo que la
expresión va a sumar esta área positiva
con esta área negativa así es que
definitivamente no es la suma de las
áreas de todos los rectángulos es esta
área de aquí menos esta área que tenemos
acá